Jordan Deluxe tu avais deux questions
pour moi il y en a trois en fait vas-y
alors dépêche-toi la première c'est
combien ce que vous gagnez par mois je
ne sais pas
possible je suis producteur de
l'émission donc je sais pas écrire
c'est tout ce qu'on la vend je sais plus
voilà
[Rires]
euros par mois
et tout le monde les locaux oui mais
attendez là je sais de trouver son
salaire à moi j'essaie de sauver ton
boulot
vous savez vraiment pas je ne sais pas
est-ce qu'il y a un moment où vraiment
vous êtes fait peur vous avez vu un un
montant où vous êtes dit je pensais
jamais gagner 4
je regarde pas ça
ne regarde pas le plus beau cadeau que
vous avez fait votre fils mon fils Ben
un immeuble
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'était pour une bonne cause en plus
c'était pour la voilà c'est pour le la
fondation du PSG c'est lors d'une vente
aux enchères et il m'a coûté beaucoup
d'argent c'est combien beaucoup d'argent
90000 euros alors c'est vrai le vélo de
vélo
pour l'association
la deuxième question c'est est-ce que
vous êtes en couple et si oui avec qui
déjà je vais vous arrêter direct je ne
suis pas en couple je suis célibataire
d'accord célibataire
[Rires]
je suis célibataire voilà là c'est tu
peux vérifier voilà c'est une personne
ici qui pouvait vous plaire autour du
plateau en femme non il y a personne ce
serait là ce soir non
ça aurait pu arriver mais pas là ça
aurait pu arriver avec une autre
chroniqueuse
est-ce que vous êtes bisexuel non pas du
tout
tu ne boufferas jamais le cul
content toi de faire ton émission le
matin et qu'il passera très bien
d'accord très bien parce que tu l'as
est-ce que ça sous-entend pardon mais tu
dois que un autre pourrait non plus
voilà je crois qu'on a fait le tour
et je note que franchement vous avez
répondu honnêtement
sur célibataire oui combien je gagne par
mois je te dis si compliqué je l'ai mais
est-ce que c'est compliqué d'être en
couple avec vous Cyril est-ce que non
c'est souvent compliqué d'être en couple
avec une personnalité dans ce cas-là
notoriété il y a le pouvoir regarde les
autres sont en couple aussi ah c'est
pour ça oui mais c'est plutôt des coupes
frivole tous ces gens là